flying into the major foreign policy
issue confronting israel's alliance with
the united states
the divergence in approach to iran and
its nuclear program
u.s secretary of defense lloyd austin is
the most senior biden administration
official
to visit israel since the new u.s
president was sworn in
after four years of a trump white house
which favored the israeli line on iran
these are different days as the u.s
explores options
for reviving the iran nuclear deal
as a major strategic partner for the
united states
our bilateral relationship with israel
in particular
is central to regional stability and
security
in the middle east during our meeting i
reaffirmed to minister gantz
our commitment to israel is enduring
and it is ironclad austin's opposite
number israeli defense minister benny
gantz
pledged cooperation in confronting what
he called a threat to international
security
the region and israel and we will walk
closely
with our american allies to ensure that
any new agreement with iran will secure
the vital
interest of the world of the united
states
prevent dangerous armrests in our region
and protect the state of israel but in
the midst of talks in vienna aimed at
finding a new agreement
the language from israel's prime
minister has been very different
benjamin netanyahu insisting that israel
would not be bound by
any deal that paved the way to an
iranian nuclear weapon
israel is already confronting iran on
multiple fronts
reportedly behind the attack on an
iranian ship in the red sea last week
regularly targeting the iranian military
inside syria
blamed by iran for assassinating its
chief nuclear
scientist last year israel's defense
minister may be talking about
cooperating with the americans
on a new deal but it'll be interesting
to see the language used by his
political rival
the prime minister benjamin netanyahu
long the most
vehement opponent of any such deal when
he meets the us defense secretary
on monday harry fawcett al jazeera west
jerusalem
let's speak to laura rockwood about all
this she is the director of the open
nuclear network and she earlier helped
write global atomic rules in
a three-decade-long legal career with
the international nuclear atomic energy
agency
she's joining us live from vienna thank
you so much miss ronwood for being with
us on al jazeera
of course any incident at a nuclear
plant a nuclear facility
is a worrying thing the iranians are
describing this as an
act of terrorism implicitly pointing the
finger at israel
first of all how much damage do you
think this facility would have sustained
if the electrical distribution grid was
indeed affected
it's really hard to say without having
more information
if you recall when the stuxnet virus was
deployed
against natanz it really did interfere
with the operation of the centrifuges
but eventually iran got the centrifuges
back up and running
so it's really hard to know until we
hear a little bit more from the
aeoi the atomic energy agency of iran
so just have to wait and see right
tehran says
it had launched new advanced centrifuges
at the site
because of uh the fire that happened
last year which they also blamed
on israel do we know exactly what type
of of work
happens and goes on at the natanz
facility
oh yes yes um the iaea has its eye on
the
natanz enrichment facility on a regular
basis
uh regardless of the jcpoa regardless of
the iran deal
so the iaea inspectors have a very good
sense of what's going on
what kind of centrifuges are spinning
how much enriched uranium is being
produced so
i don't think that's a serious issue i
think
uh this could be a brief setback
for iran but what i don't think it will
do
is deter iran from continuing
to enrich uranium and to install more
and better centrifuges
right well the timing certainly is a
very interesting and suspicious one the
iranians would say
as they are about to resume nuclear
talks indirect talks for the time being
with the u.s
trying to revive the 2015 nuclear deal
do you do you see this as perhaps being
an attempt to derail those negotiations
and
what effect could it have on the talks
in my view without a doubt this is
definitely not a coincidence
and one thing you need to remember while
it is uh
israel is the usual suspect in these
events over the last few years
one must be mindful there there are many
opponents in many different corners
to the resumption of the joint
comprehensive plan of action
not the least of which is from within
iran itself
so it certainly is not coincidental in
my view
but i think that both president rouhani
and president
biden are committed to trying to find a
peaceful resolution
to this issue and a way to get back to
the basic constraints in the jcpoa and
what would it take precisely to
return to the 2015 nuclear deal neither
side right now seems willing to
compromise what needs to happen on the
iranian side and on the american side do
you think
well i think what they're doing in
vienna if i'm
if i'm understanding it correctly is
iran is identifying the sanctions it
wishes to have listed
and the u.s is identifying those actions
which
uh they wish to have iran do and perhaps
it will be done
simultaneously i think we have very
imaginative and creative diplomats who
are negotiating this deal
so i think it is possible it happened
before at a time when nobody
believed it could so i think both sides
are
so fundamentally committed to making
this happen
that they just need to be clear about
what they want and clear about what they
are prepared to give up on
in order to achieve a peaceful solution
thank you very much for talking to us
about this thank you for your insight
laura rockwood is from the open nuclear
network joining us there
from vienna thank you for your time my
pleasure